IT IS TIME TO PLAY...
THE BLUNDER YEARS!
THE BLUNDER YEARS.
(APPLAUSE, WHOOPING)
(LIKE JOE COCKER): ♪ WHAT WOULD
YOU DO IF I SANG OUT A TUNE... ♪
LAST WEEK I ASKED YOU GUYS TO
TWEET US YOUR MOST EMBARRASSING
SCHOOL PHOTOS USING THE HASHTAG:
MIDNIGHTSCHOOLPICKS, AND, GOOD
LORD, DID YOU ANSWER THE CALL!
NOW, SINCE IT'S THROWBACK
THURSDAY, WE CALLED THROUGH THE
BEST ENTRIES AFTER A FEW
SLEEPLESS NIGHTS AND MADE A TINY
LITTLE GAME OUT OF THEM.
BUT BEFORE WE BEGIN, I'LL JUST,
UH, GIVE YOU A LITTLE TASTE--
UH, THIS IS MY SIXTH GRADE
PICTURE.
AW...
(LAUGHTER)
LOOK AT THAT.
LOOK AT THAT LITTLE GUY.
COME ON.
(APPLAUSE)
THIS LITTLE GUY WAS PRESIDENT OF
THE CHESS CLUB IN THAT PICTURE.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE JIM IN
ACCOUNTING.
>> HARDWICK: I LOOK LIKE A
PROFESSIONAL KID.
>> CHRIS, CHRIS.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH?
>> DO YOU MISS THAT GUY?
>> HARDWICK: NO. I HAD, LIKE,
TWO FRIENDS, LIKE...
>> WELL, I JUST WAS WONDERING.
>> HARDWICK: I WAS SOCIALLY
OSTRACIZED BECAUSE I WAS IN
CHESS CLUB AND I LIKED COMPUTERS
AND... VIDEO GAMES.
(AUDIENCE AW'ING)
>> SO WAS EVERYBODY.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. AND SOMEDAY I
WOULD GROW UP TO USE THAT TO GET
PITY FUCKS.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
(WHOOPING)
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU GUYS AN
EMBARRASSING SCHOOL PHOTO
TWEETED TO US FROM ONE OF OUR
LOYAL VIEWERS, AND FOR 250
POINTS, I WANT YOU TO TELL ME
WHAT THEIR SCHOOL SUPERLATIVE
WAS.
LIKE, YOU KNOW, BEST THIS, MOST
THAT.
ALL RIGHT, FIRST ONE-- @JONATHAN
GAVE US THIS ONE.
(GROANING, LAUGHTER)
(BELL DINGS)
SCOTT.
IT ALMO...
IT-IT LOOKS LIKE...
LOOKS LIKE THE PHOTOGRAPHER WAS
LIKE...
>> "OKAY, LOOK TO THE SIDE, NOT
AT ME."
>> LOOK, LIKE, LEAN.
AND... YOU'RE UGLY AS SHIT.
>> SURPRISE!
>> HARDWICK: POINTS TO GELLMAN.
AUKERMAN.
>> MOST LIKELY TO BITE OFF HIS
CAPTOR'S PENIS.
>> HARDWICK: IT ACTUALLY LOOKS
LIKE HE WAS SMILING AND THE
PHOTOGRAPHER JUST STARTED
SHITTING, AND HE WAS LIKE, "AAH!
WHAT'S HAPPENING?"
>> I'LL SIT, TOO.
>> HARDWICK: JON DALY.
>> MOST LIKELY TO MAKE THIS
NOISE: "AAH!"
>> HARDWICK: POINTS, YEAH,
POINTS.
BY THE WAY...
BY THE WAY, IN HIS AVATAR, HE'S
MAKING THE SAME GODDAMN FACE.
SAME GODDAMN FACE.
BRETT GELLMAN.
>> MOST LIKELY TO WAIT 24 YEARS
FOR A U-HAUL TRUCK TO GET STUCK
UNDER A BRIDGE.
>> HARDWICK: BRAVO, POINTS.
MORE POINTS TO BRETT GELLMAN.
AT... NEXT, @GRAHAMMOSIMANN.
AT G...
WELL, I GUESS IT MAKES SENSE
THAT HE NOW WORKS FOR 98.1 THE
BRIDGE.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, BRETT?
>> MOST LIKELY TO BE CALLED
"MA'AM" FROM BEHIND, AS IN...
AS IN, "MA'AM, PLEASE STOP
PLAYING THAT SAXOPHONE."
>> HARDWICK: RIGHT.
WAIT A MINUTE, YOU'RE WEARING A
FUCKING SADE SHIRT-- YOU DON'T
WANT HIM TO PLAY "SMOOTH
OPERATOR" ON THAT?
>> I MEAN BY MEAN KIDS, NOT BY
ME, I'D BE LIKE, "YEAH, MAN,
LET'S GO HANG OUT AND GO FUCK
OUR MOMS."
>> HARDWICK: GOOD POINT.
POINTS.
JON DALY.
>> HE'S THE MOST LIKELY TO TAKE
A SHIT IN A URINAL.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, POINTS.
AUKERMAN?
>> UM...
>> HARDWICK: I THINK THAT'S
CALLED...
>> LIKE HE THOUGHT... LIKE HE
THOUGHT THAT WAS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
YEAH.
>> KENNY G-IEST.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
FOR SURE.
NEXT ONE IS FROM USER
@BECAUSEIMJEWISH.
OH...
OH, NO.
AGAIN-- HAS NOT CHANGED THAT
MUCH AT ALL.
VERY STRIKING SIMILARITIES.
(BELL DINGS)
SCOTT.
>> UH, MOST LIKELY TO GROW UP TO
STALK CHRIS HARDWICK.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
THAT'S FINE.
>> VERY PLAUSIBLE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS, POINTS.
NEXT ONE, @BREWSKI4BROSKI.
YEAH.
IT SAYS, "FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL
OUR PARENTS DRESSED US UP LIKE
EASTERN EUROPEAN IMMIGRANTS."
(BELL DINGS)
SCOTT.
>> MOST LIKELY TO BE ETHNICALLY
CLEANSED.
>> HARDWICK: UH... WELL...
RULES DICTATE THAT THEY REACTED
WELL; I MUST GIVE YOU POINTS FOR
THAT.
JON DALY.
>> MOST LIKELY TO RUN A SLEEPER
CELL OUT OF A DELI.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
MR. GELLMAN.
>> MOST LIKELY TO BE VOTED
"SEXIEST SIBLINGS" BY THEIR
PARENTS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
LAST ONE, @ALISSATINBIX.
UH...
(BELL DINGS)
AN EXPLOSION OF COLOR.
JON DALY.
>> MOST LIKELY TO TRY AND SMOKE
A CIGARETTE OUT OF HER VAGINA.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
ACTUALLY...
>> AND BECOME... EVENTUALLY
BECOME VERY GOOD AT IT.
>> HARDWICK: I THINK SHE MIGHT
BE DOING IT IN THAT PICTURE
RIGHT THERE.
>> I THINK SO, TOO.
THAT'S THE FACE YOU MAKE.
>> HARDWICK: IT'S OUT OF FRAME.
UH, SCOTT AUKERMAN.
>> MOST LIKELY TO POSE FOR A
TINA YOTHERS FROM FAMILY TIES
WAX MUSEUM STATUE.
>> HARDWICK: WOW, SO SPECIFIC,
BUT YES, POINTS.